paige what i think we left something out
of the last video oh no i left
exclamations after the last video that's
not good okay we can fix this okay we
just need to make a video yes
oh
hello grammarians hello paige hi david
so i want to talk today about the
exclamation whoa an exclamation is a
type of sentence so previously we
covered uh three other kinds of sentence
we covered declarative sentences which
are just sort of statements right we
covered interrogative sentences which
are questions
and we covered imperative sentences
which are orders
but but i forgot to include the
exclamation i didn't actually forget i
just wanted to save space no okay um but
paige what what is an exclamation
uh so it's it's a sentence or
maybe a word that's like
an expression of really strong emotion
that's why we were screaming a lot and
stuff
those were all exclamations
so it doesn't even necessarily have to
be a sentence you said so it could just
be something like ow
right like an interjection like that
yeah that's a great example if you hurt
yourself
you might scream ow that's an
exclamation
can an exclamation also be an imperative
like if i said look out
yeah i think so right that's an order
yeah
and it's it's being
it's being exclaimed it's being yelled
so i think that's an exclamation too
so there's some overlap with like
imperative
and and exclamation sometimes
i would also say that there's probably
an overlap with declarative sentences
too that's true that's very true you
could be like ah that ogre is about to
attack the village right that that is
just a statement but you're clearly
pretty scared about it
so there's an exclamation point
but i could also walk that statement
back also as an exclamation and say i
was wrong about the ogre he's nice oh
he's just coming to say hi he's just
coming to say hi right give you a big ol
thumbs up um so we're expressing
something
we're expressing strong emotion
we could just be very excited about
something right or you can use
exclamation points when you're trying to
convey that someone is speaking at high
volume okay right so i could be yelling
across
you know the field
to
to you my pal to be like don't worry
about the ogre he's just bringing snacks
okay so there's not even necessarily
strong emotion there you just want me to
hear you because i'm far away
so paige i reckon that's
that's what an exclamation is i think so
expression of strong emotion or volume
so they can be they're not always
sentences so they can be interjections
like ow or they can be full sentences
like look out or that ogre is about to
attack the village yeah they can be a
lot of things maybe a lot of things
just like you
can learn anything
david out page out